[Musique]
m
pour
et ce jusqu'à ce que mon petit coeur qui
sentent écoutés
[Musique]
m
j'ai beau tout est allé
[Musique]
oh
et un bon
m
tieger sans écoper
[Musique]
m
qui causent les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on mate etienne
tapie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment vous êtes
ah oui
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
là
chacun des enfants qui regardent et
m'écoutent que ça sur la vie de ma mère
j'écoute tout ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est très fort c'est là c'est la
pologne qui a gagné franchement
[Musique]
mais sa valeur
aof pas ouf pas ou fait bien franchement
tout mairie on était mieux un système
politique exceptionnel merci d'avoir
acquis avec nous plus de 3 millions de
vues et sur pick up sur tic tac c'est
une folie sur tik tok et 7 coca light
c'est un truc de ouf fumée tik tok tu
vois que des gens qui font de la chanson
ces intrusions soca journée sur tik tok
moi et m'a dit qu'à la tête et première
d'ailleurs top-10 râle sur deux fronts
de tommy je sais je regarde la halle est
franchement car là je te kiffe tes
magnifiques ici et elle va faire une
grande carrière et bim bam toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]